Мощун - невеличке село поблизу Києва.
На початку вторгнення Росії в Україну
Мощун став одним із форпостів,
які допомогли українським військовим
виграти битву за Київ.
Саме на цих вулицях ЗСУ розгромили
елітні бригади російської армії.
Про запеклі бої, які тривали майже місяць,
й досі нагадує суцільна руїна.
У селі - жодної вцілілої хати.
Тут у нас був будинок. Був. Ось це був будинок.
136 кв. метрів. Залишився один фундамент.
10 березня 2022-го року, у самий розпал боїв,
родина Гавриленків втратила все майно.
Три ракети потрапили просто в хату,
а далі все воно пішло ланцюговою реакцією:
сарай згорів, трактор і все інше.
Тепер сім'я мешкає у модульному будинку,
який надали українські благодійники.
Нас там шестеро чоловік.
Батько з однієї сторони, а ми - з цієї.
Так як чоловіка немає - він в ЗСУ,
то четверо в одній кімнаті.
Юлія каже: за тимчасове житло дуже вдячна,
але найбільше мріє відбудувати власне
й хапається за кожну можливість.
Уже понад рік подає документи на програми
з відбудови, проте у відповідь…
Ніхто нічого не каже. Чекайте й все.
Чесно, ніби всі забули, що Мощун існує.
Тож живуть у модульному будинку від безвиході.
А це, каже Юлія, неабияке випробування
з дворічною дитиною на руках.
Як тебе звати? Скажи, що тебе звати Гриша.
Привіт!
Зводити нову оселю власним коштом
Гавриленки можливості не мають.
За підрахунками Юлії, необхідно
щонайменше три мільйона гривень.
Для багатодітної родини сума непідйомна,
тим паче чимало грошей із сімейного
бюджету йде на потреби чоловіка,
який служить в ЗСУ.
Чоловік у мене зараз служить в Лимані.
68-ма бригада. Ну каже, що дуже складно.
Приїхали вони із завдання, все обгорівше.
Я йому перекинула гроші, він пішов і купив.
Десять тисяч - це купити штани, берци й все інше.
Тож Юлія чекає: і на повернення чоловіка з фронту,
і на обіцяну відбудову.
А от сусід Гавриленків, пан Олексій,
який також подавався на різноманітні програми з відбудови,
зокрема й на "єВідновлення", швидко зневірився.
Відтак власним коштом замінив вікна
та відремонтував котельню.
Воно все вигоріло, але ось ці частини.
Мороз вдарив, ще лишилась вода,
й воно порозмерзалося.
Словом, порепалися труби, порепалися насоси,
то довелось ремонтувати. Наливаєш воду,
бачиш, де тече, спускаєш і заварюєш.
Загалом на ремонт пішло понад вісімдесят тисяч гривень.
І ця сума була б більшою в рази, каже,
якби не міжнародна допомога.
За підтримки ООН пану Олексію безоплатно замінили дах.
І матеріал привезли безкоштовно,
і все зробили безкоштовно.
Ну я хлопцям так: то кава, то чай.
Було риби наловив, рибою їх пригостив.
Ну дах обійшовся б десь тисяч під сто гривень,
якщо не більше.
Найбільше допомоги від українських та іноземних
волонтерів Мощун отримував торік,
одразу після деокупації Київщини.
Проте поступово інтерес до долі села зменшувався.
Нині волонтери в Мощуні - рідкість, кажуть місцеві.
Тож змушені самотужки шукати спонсорську підтримку.
Приміром, ось цей модульний будинок родині Ющенків
подарували далекі родичі зі Сполучених Штатів.
Нам ключі вручили 25 грудня на католицьке Різдво.
Ми тут не зимували, просто вмикали світло,
щоб воно просихало, бо не було каналізації.
Було сильно тут мокро, дощі були,
ми не могли закопати в землю конструкцію.
А закопали тільки цього літа, коли вже все підсохло.
І ми доробили каналізацію і перейшли сюди жити.
Ну, добрий будинок. Як нема нічого,
то дякувати богу, що так.
Зводити новий будинок власним коштом
Юрій не поспішає. Каже: гарантія на модульний -
вісім років. Тож сподівається за цей час
отримати допомогу від держави.
Таку вже не побудую, звісно, на 115 квадратів,
але на квадратів 80-90 думав будувати навесні.
Потім мене відмовили родичі.
Щоб я поки не будував. Думаю,
що ще рік-другий перечекаю.
Якщо держава не допоможе - буду сам будувати.
Жінка в мене бережлива, трохи назбирали.
У травні Мощуном прокотилася радісна звістка:
село увійшло до спеціальної урядової програми
з комплексної відбудови.
Як анонсували в уряді, шість зруйнованих населених пунктів
із різних регіонів України повністю
трансформують за принципом "краще, ніж було".
Утім, участь Мощуна у проєкті й досі під питанням.
Гальмує відновлення застаріла документація,
зокрема неактуальний генплан села.
Затвердити його можна під час сесії
Гостомельської селищної ради, проте…
Ну, просто нема сесії. У воєнний час сесія не збирається.
Ми два рази писали. Один Шмигалю писали.
До старости туди ходили всі.
А потім ще одне звернення до Зеленського писали,
щоб він якось посприяв. Інакше не виходить.
Староста села про проблему знає
й переконує: найближчим часом її вирішать.
Утім, коли саме - наразі невідомо.
Не підписаний генплан, так, немає
повноважень в міської адміністрації.
Але над цим працює начальник військової адміністрації.
І він працює добре. Сказали, що вирішить це питання.
Так. Ми чекаємо. Бачте, перед нами планування будинків.
Які, кому, куди, що та як ставити.
Тим часом у селі почали ремонтувати дорогу.
Асфальт кладуть прямісінько біля воріт Юлії.
Тиждень, як вони роблять дорогу.
Там десь труби перебили,
там десь електрику перебили.
Поки терпимо. Вибачте, але в країні йде війна,
а вони будують дорогу. Ну вона непотрібна.
Люди залишилися без будинків, без нічого.
І як дальше воно буде.
Тож разом із трьома дітьми й стареньким батьком
Юлія готується зимувати в модульному будинку.
Втім, сподівається, що наступну зиму
зустрічатиме вже у власній відбудованій оселі.
Все? Бувайте-бувайте?
З усіма прощається.
Ти хочеш собі новий будинок?
Хочемо. Хочемо ми новий будинок,
але нічого не вдається.